Your new cellmate.
The problem is that he turned over
a new leaf while in jail.
He's heading over.
That's precisely the plan.
Let's take on the job.
Damn it!
-Please, repeat--
-Good evening.
Please stop already!
Let me down immediately!
God dammit, what is that?
Gosh.
It looks like it worked too well.
-What is it?
-I'm from IT.
How will we prove she's real?
We can never prove it.
It depends entirely on them.
I never joke around with makeup. There.
I'm an FBI special agent.
Pola Dickens.
Good evening.
I'm taking over now.
No one told me.
This is my mountain.
We're not incompetent.
Does that mean
you're deliberately not arresting him?
Detective Anderson?
-No!
-Yes.
-You said, "See this to the end."
Eating after work is the best.
Arsène Lupin, Gentleman Burglar.
I'm Laurent.
I'm riding the train with him.
But he's with his wife and his kid.
But get rid of him for good.
-You stood him up three times.
-I'm not the perfect dad.
The defendant is guilty.
A jail sentence of 18 months.
And a 3-year suspended sentence.
But I'll always believe you.
Let's save some time.
I bid 60 million euros.
66 million.
67 million.
68 million.
Sold!
He should know who his grandpa was.
Take them out.
-Assane.
-I know what I'm doing.
In reality, living like a peasant
doesn't suit you.
It's not feasible for you.
You're a swindler by nature.